Yeah.
Hey, what's going on? It's Bill Burr, Eh,
it's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast said,
ah, I'm just checking in on you.
I'm just checking in on your edge.
We'd gone until this
fucking Thursday stairs day.
Jode fucking payday. I'm
actually, I'll get paid on Friday.
Well fuck you and your job, man.
I used to get paid on Thursday.
I skip paid on Thursday and
I used to keep my money.
I used to have my money.
I spent it on May.
Well, where do you want to go? Who's
it up to make? Oh, I mean depended.
She got none.
My life was mine and that
260 bucks a week that I made.
I had a fucking car
payment for $138 a month.
I was rolling in it, you
know, fucking rolling in it.
I didn't even realize
it. I was like, Oh gee,
wouldn't it be great someday to
fucking get out there in the world?
Yeah.
Get my own place. Have a car,
drive down the street, man. Right.
What happens? You get out there
and you fucking, you stupid.
You like a little toddler walking,
crawling up to a fucking Cobra and
they forgot to so its mouth shut.
You know like how they do that
shit over in India. You know,
we just born into a family of
snake jam as whatever happens over,
they haven't seen that video. I
assumed it was in India, you know,
and don't get mad at me.
Blame Hollywood. Alright.
I've hung out with disease a few times.
I never,
I never brought the Colbert thing up.
I forgot the F to find out
if this was true or not.
I could have been like a zs a is this
or is this not a your people things
specifically.
And then he could have been like Dodd
no built is actually this snake charmers
all over, uh, all over the world.
You know when I would've said it,
was it fair enough? But
I didn't. So anyway,
she ever seen those fucking videos where
they saw the goddamn cobras fucking
mouth shut. Can I curse more than
that sentence? Have you seen those?
Um, have you seen that footage
where they take the unknown? And I,
at this point with this voice,
I'd have to know the Latin name for Cobra.
They sell the fucking things mouth shut
and then they have a baby crawl up to it
and the,
the snake is like freaking out cause
you're gonna understand it small as a baby
is to a person for a snake. It's still
pretty fucking big. Like what is,
what is that?
Is that a mongoose?
Is that going to run up and just grabbed
my face and give me a couple of shakes
and then that's it.
Last thing I see in my life is the
inside of a fucking Mongooses esophagus.
Okay.
That's what the snake is thinking.
It's just a snake only has
one fucking expression.
You know, reptiles are like
redefine resting bitch face
reptiles never look like
they're in a good mood
or they just stay
on. They just have like, no, they just
kind of fucking sitting there like a frog.
Right. It's not a fucking reptile
today I'm fib Ian. Well whatever it is,
doesn't have any hair on it.
They have a little bit, oh, that was
less cool. Less Claypool's line. Right.
Was talking about some woman said
she was finer than frog hair. Um,
what the fuck song was that?
That was one of his solo albums.
His bucket of Bernie brains.
Something of the hunt.
I can't remember. Oh,
my brain's going. Oh, I bought,
I don't know where to start.
I was talking about babies fucking
messing with, with uh, cobras.
I Dunno how I got there.
I don't even what's going on?
How many minutes just went by three
42 just like that. Just like that.
Three 42 you drive home and
you drive to work. Right?
Well maybe you have really tiny headphones
and your wife's bitching at you right
now. You listen to this.
Oh, your boyfriend. I Dunno.
I Dunno what the fuck
he's doing. Um, yeah.
You had that dream that you're going to
go out in the real world and your money
was going to be made and it was going
to go into your pocket. And Dude,
I'm going to have a fucking keg of Raider.
We here fucking Pool Table Air Hockey.
And what happens
20 years goes by 20 years
where they go 20 years at Aldo,
right?
Bob Seger.
Sometimes I sit and wonder where
they gone pass smart is Bob Seger.
Bob Seger was smart enough to
realize that most people lose.
And he sang right to those fuckers and
they showed up with their fucking what
does,
what does that old Milwaukee's right.
And they sat right in the front row at
that bottom, lips quivering, you know.
And then the wise you look over
like, oh honey, what's the matter?
And then they'd have to slap their wife
cause you couldn't show that you cried
back then when the song first came up.
Now I can sit there,
cupcakes and kittens on your shirt is a
man sit there Indian style wearing yoga
pants and you, your wife, you know,
I don't know what she's doing.
She's got work boots on and a trucker hat.
I don't know what goes
on with the youth today.
I don't pretend to know I'm
an older person. All right.
All I know is somehow all the bands went
into the computer and they never came
out again.
And then they just became one person.
You know, like Mayweather
says form like Voltron, right?
Doesn't Voltron like one guy. I know what
the fuck it is. Wow. The hell would they?
I mean I'm from the age of like,
I mean I was too old for stomp or
four by fours when they came out.
That's how I played with
Tonka trucks. People. Okay.
There was no batteries in that thing.
You wanted it to move,
you had to fucking push it.
All right.
Then you wrote those things
down the driveway and right
before went into traffic,
you bailed off of it and you prayed to
God that it would make the other side
without getting run over by a
milk truck. Right. There you go.
So
unlike you,
I also don't know what I'm talking
about at this point anyways. Yeah.
You thought it was going to be all yours,
right? In 20 years fucking goes by.
Yeah.
Okay. And then one day you walk
a d house and you just looking
around at all the shit and all it
really is is it's just a bunch of shit.
What's the,
what is all this shit?
Fucking tables and couches chair.
We're gonna fucking chairs here.
How many kids do you plan on having? Why
are there so many? God Damn chairs. One,
oh,
there's no money to do this.
A perfect area right here where
a drunk kid could go. You know?
What is that stupid picture?
Why don't you take it off the
wall and put up a fucking dad?
I just feel like that wouldn't look right.
Be kind of awkward. Why would that
be awkward? You know, it's awkward.
Every room. Vaguely looking the same. We
look like we live in a furniture store.
There's nothing in here but furniture.
How about some function?
What about that game where
you try to punch it as hard
as you can to seal strong?
You are, you know where that
game would you shoot the baskets.
You can't just have one of those. I
don't know. I just feel like that was,
you know,
maybe in the garage.
Is there a way to put it behind
the house and down the street?
I don't want to have company over and
have them see that you're having fun.
I want
my wife better not listen to this.
I want them to come over and see that
you are totally in control under my
control and you are,
you are listening to the fucking
decisions that I want to make.
I'm just fucking with you. Um, anyways,
whatever. Most of that isn't
truthful. Only the set part. Um,
it starts to everybody either
get paid today and tomorrow.
What do you do with your money?
Huh?
What are you gonna do when Your Bank of
America evidentaly their entire fucking
system was down. How does that happen?
That's not scary enough. Is it?
Jesus Christ? I hope they didn't.
You know, I should look that up.
I should look that up before
I cause a run on a bank.
Is that the name of a song? Run on
a bank? Is that a Bob Seger Song?
Was that a no surprise? Oh, that's
love on the rocks. Not Run on a bank.
Love on the rocks.
Ain't no big surprise.
I thought it was run on a bank
grabbing by their ties.
Especially with him.
Milk, white fucking ties.
Why does my internet suck
in every fucking room? Yeah.
I swear to God, who am I? Internet
company is they have to have a poster.
Be on the welcome.
We need more customers like this.
He pays 10 times what he should
fucking pay. It never works.
And he never complains unless he's
doing his podcast. But who gives a fuck?
Cause he never calls us.
So what do we care?
We just keep taking his fucking
money. All right, here we go.
Bank of America.
Fuck yeah.
Everyone in the world is jealous of us.
Yeah.
Be One wants to be like us.
That's why they hate on us.
All right. Maybe. Maybe we've gotten
out of line in a few areas. All right.
Evidently it's loading.
You know what I mean?
Watching my computer. Try to get on the
Internet, like waiting for it for load.
It's like watching me try to remember
shit from fucking two days ago.
Yeah.
Oh you sneaky fucking bastards.
This isn't what I wanted.
I didn't want your website.
I wanted to fucking gossip.
Yeah.
What do I gotta hit? Bank of America
Slash Tmz Bank of fucking America.
Here we go again. Bank of America. Google.
Here we go. Here we go. What
do you got? What do we got?
Customers shout out of accounts during
a parent Bank of America outage.
Oh boy.
Okay.
Oh boy. I'm just picturing someone
with one of those. What's that?
White masks that those fucking hackers
where when they want to shut down the
corporations. Um, all right, here we go.
Bank of America customers was shut out
from their accounts. Oh, an advertisement.
Oh, Ralph's. Jesus. You know what?
I will buy a Honeywell am all right.
What Bac Bank of America customers were
shut out from their accounts for several
hours,
Wednesday in a system outage.
Okay.
You know, somebody fucking, you know,
didn't get dialysis or their
heart stops at you, would you,
would you as such with with so at
the feet of these fucking cops,
coral springs resident,
Eric's, oh, he's asleep.
But you never think you
could run that fast.
And those work boots and
there he goes down the street.
So we got what looked like a phishing
email from the bank Wednesday and
immediately started calling customer
service to see if something was wrong,
a message on his online accounts that
it could not pull up his information.
When we called,
this local branch manager said that local
managers are calling each other trying
to figure out what caused what appeared
to be a national outage and why they
were unable to provide certain services
like what provides you with the money
that you need. Um, on down detector.com,
a website that tracks reports,
have system outages.
Reports started spiking after 11:30
AM and the website was inundated with
comments from Bank of American customers
don't what the fuck send around the
country saying they couldn't
access online banking.
Computer did it by 1:00 PM they had
received nearly 1000 reports of problems,
but by Wednesday evening all although
some customers were still reporting
problems that never reports,
I'd gone down considerably to about
200 and then this is their common,
I know that the tape is working
quickly to bring everything back up.
As time progresses,
they should be able to go back online.
I would really love to
see what really happened.
Okay.
A Bank of American system y system wide
outage on the damn closing on closing on
my, and there's nothing I can
do about it. Bank of America,
you closed my bank account with no notice.
How can I deposit my check when I no
longer have an account stuck in Thailand?
What is up with not being able to transfer
as the system has been down for three
hours? Oh, Jesus. Jenny. That's nothing
compared to the guy stuck in Thailand.
The clerk at Bank of America just said,
I can't make a Dakota deposit
because a nationwide disruption.
Anyone know what's up? All
right. Yeah. Okay. All right,
well let's just hope that was a one
time thing. Okay. Nothing to see here.
That's fucking scary.
That's why you got to have your
money in like three different banks.
I don't care if you get 40 bucks,
put 15 one 10 and another.
What do we got left in? Was that 25 you
can 15 the last one, right? 1515 and 10.
It's a fucking shell game out there, man.
Um, and when you got to pay your rent,
you write three to four checks.
Why don't you just write
it for the full of mouth?
Because I'm not going to get stuck in
Thailand. You can't, what do you care?
As long as it all works. Um, all right,
let's get back to the
podcast here. Um, I am,
when you listen to this,
I will be in New York City.
By the time you listened
to this. I am going to the
airport to not to, not to not,
um,
I'm going back to New York
for about a week.
I'm going to be there
for a week, week, um,
doing an acting gig out there.
As I mentioned before,
they rebooting sex in the city and uh,
I'm going to be playing this
Cynthia Nixon character. Um,
they said to keep my head shave. Maybe
they could do some sort of, I dunno, post,
uh, you know, cancer free, I guess.
Craig Nixon, I don't know what my fucking
name is going to be, but you know,
I wanted it to be the, the fabulous
one. Whatever the fuck her name is.
What the fuck was her name?
I saw him one time at a Knicks game.
She looked still with beautiful, you know,
but they're thin fucking head. What the,
you know,
she needs more head and I need less head.
If we could somehow combine the
two of us, I think, you know,
they could have something there. The
fuck is her name. She started it,
honey. Remember Cynthia Nixon
and you don't remember the
other one. Sarah. Jessica.
That's right.
S J p she had a fucking basketball shoe.
How about those red sox won in
the last three out of four. Yeah,
I do like that shit.
Okay.
What two and two against the fucking
yaggies all where then we, uh,
took two or three from the Blue Jays.
I watched the whole blue Jay series.
I enjoy you. And what's great is
Dennis Eckersley up in the booth.
The man loves the game. The man played
the gang. The man can talk the game.
God dammit. He does it
for nine innings. I love,
especially when it's
like a low scoring game.
If you have a fucking picture up there,
he's incredible little x.
You make it exciting.
Think it's going to kill me with the
fucking I do break and ball here.
Guy Throws a breaking ball. He's
like, get this guy that he's like,
it's like he has fucking ESP. It's
like he pitched in the fucking league.
Everybody. How does this man
know what happens if you gently,
the Yankees made some sort of move to
cock block the red sox. But you know,
I tried to get annoyed by that, but
you know, it's been three world series.
I think we're good. Who gives
a shit? We're in first place.
I think it's kind of over. I think
the Yankees Red Sox thing is, uh,
it'll never be what it
was and I'm happy for it.
I'm actually glad that it won't
be, I don't miss it because,
uh, you know, it usually didn't work
out for, I worked out for us once
and then it was over. Um, anyways,
uh, oh by the way, still in posted a
picture of my drum kit. I swear to God.
You know,
I'm going to fucking send it right now,
so I'm going to send it right fucking now.
You probably already see it by the time
it's things posted. Let me just fucking,
it's not the greatest picture. I was
by myself. What do you want from me?
Come on. Oh Shit. You know, I was
reading something the other day.
I'm going to get to it.
Um,
about good fellas.
It was this really cool thing that
said 30 things you might not know about
Goodfellas and it's actually 30
things that I didn't fucking know. Um,
even though they still talked
about how, uh, how am I funny?
What do I amuse you? What
am I, some sort of clown.
Everybody knows that that was Improv,
but like patching,
those guys were saying we would improv
it and then he would write it all down
and then, you know, take the
best parts in that write it down.
Then you had to memorize it,
then you'd fucking go do it.
Which makes sense because you can't like
fucking improv every different take and
then he moves to cameras around you saying
different Shit that you did the other
time and then it's not, it's not
going to line up. So anyways, he was,
here's what it was the best,
one of the best ones. Um,
that whole tracking scene where,
um,
Henry Hill takes carron
what did you Joe, Oh, you just killed us.
Okay.
Savvy,
right. Um, he takes her
in through the kitchen,
right then he'll track and shot and
that was one sentence in the book that
Scorsese got this idea. There's a,
there's a line in that book wise Guy,
whatever the fuck the one that
Henry Hill wrote, it said, um,
on crowded nights when people were
lined up outside and couldn't get in the
doormen used to let Henry, I'm
sorry, the prince really small.
My eyes are going used to let Henry
and our party in through the kitchen,
which was filled with Chinese cooks and
we go upstairs and sit down immediately.
That one sentence in
that poll fucking book,
I mean, how many times did you read that
book? He just read it one time and said,
oh, that gives me an idea. Bam. Um,
you'd think it would at
least be a paragraph.
Yeah,
some sort of story attached to it.
It's just one goddamn sentence
and that guy's fucking
able to do all of that.
And that my friends is why he's one of
the great directors and all the time.
All right, let's, let's get a good
one here. Let's get a good one.
Yeah.
Oh No.
Dottie.
Oh, there we go. There we go.
Symbols that are fucked up angle.
I had to run out of there.
I'm a dad now.
It's like whenever I get a fucking chance,
I run over there.
I ran over there this morning.
I literally played four
songs and then went to work.
I didn't stretch it all
cause I didn't have time to,
and then my fucking forearms and hands
were all fucked up. I'm an idiot.
All right, let me send this right now.
You guys are literally listening to me.
Send a fucking picture.
Uh,
[inaudible] oh, guess who wants to come
back? Guess who wants to come back?
Okay.
After after fucking dump in this podcast.
Guests who wants to come back?
Huh?
After a,
it's not nature's box.
Okay.
It's a hold on a second.
Post this with pod cast.
You can't, I didn't say that. Alright.
Guess the draft kings wants to come
back with a fuck. Did they go? Huh?
What the fuck is wrong with you?
Um,
did you hear what's his face got 'em
they're going to be backed by the way,
cause they said,
I can say whatever the fuck I want with
means I can make the advertising is
funny as I want you to meet you
guys all listen and then you go,
that's all that's all advertising is
just get people to listen and maybe
somebody will buy.
Um,
there was a rumor I heard
that,
um, what's his face? Connor. Connor.
Connor Mcgregor got knocked out
by your sparring partner and a,
I looked it up and what I love was made,
whether it is like,
I don't believe it until I see
footage, I don't believe it. Like,
maybe that was a strategy by my McGregor
and it kind of all got fucking just
explained away like, no, it
didn't happen. So there you go.
There's one for you guys who are still
going to order it. There was no proof.
It was debunked by the name of
Greg Kamp Mayweather wouldn't
that does not believe it.
So there's still a chance,
there's some stupid article out there
calling Conor McGregor yet another great
white hope. It's like this is
not another great white hope.
Great White Hope would be if he was an
actual inboxing trying to win a fucking
title.
Yeah.
You know this guy holds two titles.
He already is a champion.
Okay. He already has a champion, you know,
and it's not a whites only league. So I
don't know. Always a great white hope.
This is a fucking spectacle.
That's what this is too goddamn spectacle.
I am going to try so fucking hard to
order it already agreed with Rogan that I
might watch it the next week with them.
He does this thing where you've just
fucking watch it together and you talk
about it. I might do that with Rogan. If
I can find some God damn time to do it,
I have to do it. Um, that's also
a good way to watch it for free,
for free.
Um,
maybe that's what I'll do.
I'll be the fucking grumpy guy that didn't
watch it and then I'll solo ready to
watch it and really just a tight fuck.
I'm going to watch it for free. Huh?
Remember that expression fucking
ante up yet tight. Fuck. Hey,
does anybody know how the
expression on the arm came about?
We're trying to figure that
out today in the writer's room.
Meaning it's for free.
The best they could get is that it's,
it's a policeman slang on the arm
and all I could think was, you know,
the long arm of the law, the
arm of the law. Why is, why,
how does the expression on the arm
come about?
What is the origin?
That means it's free.
Don't pay for these drinks there
on the arm. Can anybody tell me,
cause people already told me p's and q's.
Mind your own ps and Qs came from the
bars and the pubs where they used to give
beer in pints and courts.
So when people got a little,
you know,
out of line and sticking their nose in
other people's business or getting ready
to fight a mind,
your p's and q's,
you'll look at your fucking glass.
You don't look at anybody else or
whatever the fuck it meant. Right.
So I like that shit. So if you could
tell me how on the arm came about,
I don't give a shit. If you make
up stuff, I'll read it like it's,
it's a fact dental ended up on Wikipedia
and then at least people will have an
answer. Um, anyways, so these fucking
Toronto Blue Jay fans would talking
shit cause I actually watched that whole
fucking 14 and end game.
MMM.
Where Hanley Ramirez hit the walk
off home run, right. It was three,
three after regulation and then
13, um, after nine innings,
what are the fuck you say in this sport?
And then,
and like the 12th inning or something
like that, blue jays scored a run,
went up four to three and then we somehow
scored a run, made it four to four.
And then Hanley Ramirez on the bottom,
bottom of the 14th, hit a walk off,
crushed a hanging curve ball out onto
the fucking mass pike there and loved
Eckersley he was saying, he was saying
that the handle is going, I love you.
I love it cause he just, we just wants
to go home. It was fucking hilarious.
MMM.
Especially cause we that 19 and a game
with the Yankees a few days earlier.
But um,
oh Jesus,
what the fuck was I talking about?
I literally just forgot
everything I was talking about.
There was a point I was trying to make
there on the arm then to the red sox
and then fucking out my year down my pant
leg and I don't know where the fuck it
went out on that and what the fuck I
was talking about there. Oh, I know.
I was talking shit.
Why didn't talk shit?
These fucking a blue Jay fans are
giving me shit. So out of nowhere,
this fucking drum company symbol making
company that I'd never heard of before
called dream symbols. I don't know
where it starts talking shit going egg.
If, if uh, I forget I have to rent it,
the Red Sox win at the Red Sox win.
We'll give you a free bag as symbols.
If the Blue Jays wind,
uh, you know, you got to give
us free advertising. So the
Red Sox win. They're like,
ah, fuck it. What kind of symbols
do you want to whether they would,
if they were even serious,
I was just like,
I'm not going to be a bag of fucking
symbols. I already have symbols.
I can't play the cymbals.
I have.
Why would I take a bag of yours that
you could actually sell to someone who
knows how to play drums? So just for
the fuck of it, I'm gonna, you know,
but if I'm going to start the
advertising with a free read,
I've never heard of these guys. Dream
symbols, dream symbols. Yet at Ge,
we could have some symbols.
Have them in a bag, ma'am.
Uh, though relatively
new on the market dreams,
cymbals and gongs produced
worldclass handmade producers.
Worldclass handmade symbols out of
a factory in China's Wu Han region.
Am I going to be put on a watch list?
I didn't know you.
I thought we thought
those guys were the enemy.
Okay.
Which is crafted excellent
gongs for generations,
for drummers searching for their own
style. Dream is a dream come true.
Each symbol has its own unique voice,
enhancing musicians
distinct in this dreams.
I actually listened to get us a
couple of people play the cymbals.
They sound pretty good,
you know,
and I would imagine because they're
lesser known, Aka not Siljan,
not Zildjian, not Sabian, none fucking
paste or paicey over the fuck you say it.
Meinl all the kids play meinl now
everybody's got to play the MEINL.
She want to be different.
Why don't you play dream symbols or don't?
I don't give a fuck.
They're not paying me.
You can buy the set of these symbols and
roll them down the fucking hill for all
I give a shit all right now
into the real stuff. All right.
That was just a warmup. Maybe I'll
start doing that. Free advertising.
Just a warmup.
I apologize if I'm making a lot of noise.
I've got a cough drop and
fucking my voice. Oh, who is it?
Oh, look who's here. Hey
Sweetheart. My daughter's walking.
She's already knocking on doors.
Guess who learned how to crawl?
She crawls like an inchworm. Ah,
you don't care about your toys though,
do you? I love this new shiny thing.
She does what she sees and she
looks away. What's up, buddy?
You're going to hang out.
Watch another 14 things are red
sox baseball with me tonight.
We actually already won. Oh, okay.
All right. It's hot as hell in here.
Turn it on if you don't mind.
Okay, bye. Bye. Hey Nia,
what would you do if somebody
had that level of bad breath?
I read that thing to you,
val.
It's Osis and literally had like that
fucking slime along the gum line.
There's no way you're kissing
them, right? No, it's too gross.
Would you say anything?
I honestly think
it depends on how much he likes her.
You know what I mean? If you really,
really liked her, like, damn, I couldn't
really see myself with this girl.
Then you say something.
How do you see past,
you know what all I could think of person.
All I could think of was
when you know when they,
just the day when they just empty the
dumpster and you look inside of it and all
that. Fucking that liquid slime.
That's all I could. Ugh. God,
no.
I feel like if someone is that
poor with their dental hygiene,
I feel like that definitely is a red
flag, to be honest. If it were me, yeah,
you're not going downstairs.
You've seen the attic. Yeah,
and I don't want to see the base
right now.
I know.
She's so cute.
Okay. All right. Bye.
Turn on the AC. You don't mind?
I'd bug me last night. By the way.
You all impressed that I
got her to go to sleep.
It bugs me
every time I think I'm out.
You pull me back in. Yes, I know,
but I was trying to compliment you.
I know you felt,
you know
I didn't know yet. I don't know why the
difficulties getting her to go to sleep.
You were like,
oh that just means I don't want to do it.
I can do it. I just don't want to do it.
Oh
really? Cause you made it seem like
I like you made me feel bad for you.
Like you felt like, oh it's not
like I do it everyday like you do.
Like you felt somehow
it bothered you inside?
No, I just knew it was easier. No,
I just knew it was easier for you to do
it cause you know you can always tap out.
It's like drunk drivers with Uber's,
you can always take your boob out
and then put her to sleep with that.
I can't do that. Okay. I'm a
man without a country there.
Right. And I thought that, yeah,
I thought that meant that you felt like
you didn't really have a place in terms
of like getting her to go to sleep, but
now I'm realizing that you're just lazy.
So
Lazy. I worked all day in a writer's
room staring at a computer screen,
trying to think of chokes
for animated children.
Okay.
Um, all right. Just for that,
I'm drinking tonight and I'm
going to be really belligerent,
extra belligerent tonight.
I know she's adorable. And you know
what? Adorable is not funny. So
for the past five minutes,
you keep calling me back yet.
Do you see what she does?
Is she see, she yells at me.
Could you put the AC on police,
sweetheart,
you have me that one more time. I swear
to God. I'm going to turn. All right.
All right.
I gotta read this one thing for you.
I read this one thing for you. No,
I'm trying to lead.
Goodbye. Put the AC on.
Don't doubt out.
All right.
You could have got me worse.
He could've got me worse.
Um, alright. Passionate women hit hard.
I don't feed. I've ever noticed that.
You did some chicken,
which says no direction.
She bawls her fist up and then you can
literally just continue eating your club
sandwich.
But if he gets a woman with passion that
or if they had an older brother that's
going to fucking hurt a little
bit. Alright. Audibles doctor Katz.
Yeah.
Doctor Katz. Is this the comedian?
Doctor Katz. Uh, Jonathan Katz.
I used to open for this guy way
back in the day when I started out.
He's fucking hilarious.
Genius Doctor Katz.
The audio files is the new comedy series.
Free now@audible.com doctor Katz to
cult classic TV comedy is black is back.
Sorry,
that was a black comedies
as a premium podcast
with the original cast at
audible.com/doctor Katz. Ah, Jesus
Christ. Jonathan, if you listen to this,
I want to do an episode
eavesdropped.com oh eavesdrop on top
comics on couch with Hollywood's favorite
shrink. Sarah Silverman,
Ted Danson, Ray Romano,
weird Al Yankovic. Kristen
Schaal, Maria Bamford,
Paul left Tompkins.
That's how fuck you look at that.
That's all a listers right there.
Some guy named Jon Hamm
and somebody named,
yeah,
the fuck is that
is I got like half the copy.
It says some somebody named Moore,
then that's it.
Comedians finally get the therapy they
need and you get free antidepressants in
your ear on Doctor Katz,
the audio files exclusively now at
audible.com/doctor cats. All that's
awesome. Oh look who's back. Oh Shit.
Bout Oh Doh Doh beyond days me ids I've
been watching the fucking socks do,
do,
do beyond these B and d nights and
saw off on my cock and my balls and my
fucking tanked goes around on my ass.
I always say,
hey TDOT, I fucked it up,
but who gives this ship? Um,
fucking squat non dream symbols and
it doesn't hurt. All right, me, undies
me undies are the softest, most
comfortable underwear you'll ever wear.
Period in summer is the perfect time
to figure out how little your balls are
going to sweat while you
upgrade your underwear drawer.
Because everyone is thinking about
looking good and feeling good and beyond.
These are the ultimate feel.
Good undies.
Every pair of me undies is sustainably
sourced and made from micro modal, modal,
a fabric softer,
three times far softer than cotton
because me undies.com I've got to get
glasses,
man,
because me undies come in all kinds of
colors and patterns and they release new
limited edition patterns each
month that always sell out.
This month's pattern were designed by
legendary 80s clothing brand cross colors
with names that live up to their
bold design and bright colors.
Increase d piece should it be [inaudible].
There's another one called you dig.
That's where people itchy balls and the o.
G o Jesus,
Granddad with his balls hanging
down. This would it be spandex, um,
to hold everything together.
You got to see them for yourself.
And right now you'll say 20% off your
first pair and receive free shipping only
at [inaudible] dot com slash burn if you
don't love your first pair of me undies
,
they're free.
Get 20% off your first pair plus free
shipping at [inaudible] dot com slash bird
that's Mandy's dot com slash
Mian he's dot com slash bar
two more, two more, two more.
All right. Lift, lift man.
Um, Lyft knows that their drivers
are what keep them moving.
So they do everything they can to make
sure the drivers are happy on every trip.
Lyft is the ride sharing company that
believes in treating its people better
lift belly.
I love this shit.
I love this Hatfield and Mccoy
thing that's going on with them.
And that other company
that rhymes with Uber.
Okay.
Yeah.
When I read this copy,
what I learned from Lyft is that if you
drive for that other company that rhymes
with Boober,
they evidently treat you like shit
and you don't get tipped or something.
I don't know what the fuck happens,
but that, that totally good. No. Yeah.
This is the place.
This is the ride sharing app that
gives a fuck about their drivers.
Okay.
Lyft is the ride sharing company that
believes in treating it's people better.
Lift believes that being a ride sharing
drivers should be fun if you're having a
good time. So are the
passengers, uh, well, yeah, not
if you're partying. You know,
I don't have too much fun up there, buddy.
Okay. My license your hands there. Uh,
if you're choosing a ride
sharing company to drive for,
go with a company that treats you better.
Like Lyft.
Lyft was the first to offer in
APP tap tipping. When you tribe,
when you drive for Lyft,
you'll keep 100% of the tips.
Drivers had been paid over $200 million
in tips since the feature was introduced.
Lift as even taking the
guesswork out of pickups.
The new amp device uses color coding
to help passengers find the drivers.
You can earn hundreds of dollars a week
plus tips. Want to earn more money? Well,
do you drive more? It's never
been easier to give you self. Uh,
I'll drive more. It's never been
easier to give yourself a raise.
That's all I gotta do is work more.
Well, that's kind of how every job works,
isn't it? Unless you want salary.
Uh, it's a simple formula.
Happy drivers mean happy passengers.
Maybe that's why nine out of 10 Lyft rides
get a perfect five star rating and go
to [inaudible] dot com slash bird today
and get your $500 new driver bonus.
That's lyft.com/burr
lyft.com/bar I don't know
why I just thought this,
but I don't think Ferrari's going
to catch Mercedes. I just don't.
I don't know what the
fuck's going on over there.
I know this season is only halfway over,
but I don't know
both Ferrari's both fucking left front
tire is both in the final five laps.
Yeah,
no,
it's like a bad fucking Sitcom.
Okay.
I'm sorry with all the fucking
mealy mouth on this podcast.
I'm trying not to do it on the mic.
It's just I got this halls in my mouth
because my fucking voice is shot once
again and I got all this actin to do,
so I'm taking a break,
a momentary hiatus from
screaming my jokes on stage.
You know, I just really need to, do
I need to break smarter jokes? Yeah.
All I gotta do is just come out the
same, wear a suit, bing, bang, boom,
and I'm done. All right. Simply safe.
Summer is prime time for burglary.
That was fucking cops.
Why can't they do it in the winter when
you're already miserable? You know,
you having a good time? I think.
I really think she's the one.
Where's my furniture? Uh,
summers primetime for Burghley's.
So now is the time to protect your home.
For a limited time.
You can take a whopping $100 off.
Simply saved some special summer package
that is simply saves biggest ever
summer sale.
It has everything you need to protect
your home and arsenal of security sensors
to secure each door and window.
You're simply saved.
System comes with a panic button,
a blaring extra siren and a wireless
connection to authorities and police
dispatch.
Just don't leave it in your bed.
So when you roll over and you're sleeping
in a wake up with three good cops with
that gun in your face. Yeah,
I swear to God, I live here.
Um, your family, your
home and everything in it.
Stay safe around the clock with simply
safe. There are no long term contracts,
no installation costs and no hidden fees.
And 24, seven professional monitoring.
It's just 1499 a month for a panic button.
How many Sig Jodie foster played for
paid for that fucking panic room.
And what an idiot she had. The whole
room, all you needed was a button.
Once you press that, the attack
was going to be like, oh fuck.
And he's going to leave
you press the button,
right?
Call to action. Get a hundred dollars off
to summer security package. It's simply
safe.com/bar a No.
Simply safe bird.com.
Now the sale ends July 31st.
That's simply safe bird.com to get $100
off simply safe.com simply safe bar.com
fuck.
All right.
I'm just going to swallow
this fucking thing.
Wow. There we go. All right. Sorry.
33 fucking minutes of me fucking
sloshing around here at 37 38 minutes.
All right. So anyways, I'm
going to be in New York,
sweating my balls off for the next
fucking week. Being the new Cynthia Nixon.
And uh, you know what
kills me is, uh, I just,
I found out too late that guns and roses
is going to be playing at the Apollo
theater that night.
The 30th anniversary,
30th anniversary of the,
um,
of appetite for destruction. They're
going to be doing it there. I,
I fucking could have figured out a
way to weasel my way into that show.
It's done through
Sirius Xm.
God knows I've done enough shit over
there and I completely fucked myself cause
I didn't realize that show was going on.
And then I'm going to be in New
York and while I'm in New York,
John fucking mayor with the night game
opening up with Davey latch on drums at
the La Forum.
Steve Jordan on drums,
two of my favorite drummers of all
fucking time to incredible fucking bands.
One of the best venues to
see a god damn concert.
And I show up like a fucking day or
two later and I missed that. You know,
I just feel like I moved everything.
Um, anyways, that's the podcast.
Thank you guys so much for listening.
I hope you have a wonderful weekend.
You can't. Um, yeah, that's
it. Listen to this music is,
we uh,
transferred to another half hour free
shit here from a Thursday afternoon
podcasts from a Thursday
gone by in a year.
That already happened or maybe
it's early this year. I don't know.
I don't choose them. That's
it. I'll talk to you on Monday.
You were afraid of the guy
ecologist at a fucking, uh, I
am a 28 year old college guy.
Who has, was it Jane or
Phobia? The fear of women?
I've never heard of this.
Uh, he said when I was a kid,
I used to get the shit kicked out of
me and girls would always spread rumors
about me and it would really
screw with my mind. Wait a minute.
You didn't get along with men or women.
Well, what were you, what were you doing?
You know what? That's the last
thing you needed to hear. Well,
what's wrong with you?
I'm sorry. Forgive me.
I'm not a trained professional, so you
know, you're asking a moron and you know,
I'm gonna behave accordingly.
Here we go. As I grew up,
I started to resent and hate all the
people around me that my mother tells me
about false rape accusations.
And that makes, oh,
and that makes females look even
more scarier than they already were.
See,
guys just kicked the shit out of you.
Females psychologically fuck you up bad
and don't even have a tint of remorse or
empathy.
Yeah.
Oh Jesus Christ.
All right dude.
So your mother's a psycho and she
put all these fears on you. Yeah.
You gotta maybe I would
seek some professional help
before you turn into Norman
Bates. Uh, all right,
let's continue this then.
I hear about all the women raping men
in the divorce courts and in general
adding more fuel to the fear. Dude. Yeah.
You're, you're over thinking this shit.
I mean, you've probably heard half
of that from me, but I'm an idiot.
Don't listen to me.
He said it's gotten to the point where
when a female introduces herself to me,
I just see her as a potential mind
raping and prolonged exercise of getting
verbally abused. So I just
always say sorry, but I have
somewhere to be right now.
Goodbye.
Huh?
And I walk away, sir, can
I steal that from you?
I want to use that next time we get
pulled over guidelines is Reza. Sorry,
when I have somewhere to be
right now, goodbye. And you just,
just act like the rain man.
And they'll fucking leave you alone.
That's actually brilliant.
He said they scare me so much,
but I'm still attracted to them. Oh
my God, Dude. You listen, you gotta,
you gotta you gotta get past this.
Hopefully you're still
young and this is early on,
but this is something where you were,
you know,
everybody is trying to go towards the,
uh,
we'll just call it a whatever
planet live happily ever after.
But if you're off by just one degree,
you're not really going to notice
when you're 22, 24, you know,
but by the time you're 40, you're going
to be about a million miles off course.
So let's try and get you some help.
I would go see a therapist, sir.
Um,
and I know I've been joking around,
but I kind of have to do that
because this is a podcast. But, um,
well actually because it's a
podcast that's supposed to be funny.
I'm not saying you can't
have a serious podcast. Um,
yeah, we'd go get some help quickly
and I would get rid of all those fears.
And I would say a lot of
the fears are probably, uh,
put into your head by your mom when you
were really young and you need to try
and get those out of there before they
take any more route than they already do
already have. Well, let's finish
here. He said, my mind says,
stay the fuck away while my Dick
says do it. Do it. Fucking do it. Uh,
but in this climate of unrestrained female
hypo agents and what the fight,
I mean,
this shit that makes women invade male
spaces and makes them change everything
to suit them through. Dude, you're taking
your fucking fear of women. You're,
you're, you're, you're
blowing by me. Listen,
are you a great guy?
If you're a great guy,
there's a great woman out
there for you and the,
and it's a beautiful thing
then at all like this.
What you're doing is you're taking the
worst of the worst of females and you're
praying it with the broad
brush. All right. Um, AH,
Jesus Christ. I'm relating
to this guy here. He said,
I'd rather stay celibate for life
right now. I don't relate to that.
I am a loner to a vast degree,
but I got a loving family to back me up.
So I am on the fringe or anything.
I plan on just working
towards my career and it did.
I write this like 20 years ago.
Jesus Christ plan on just working
towards my career in education,
but either way I'll have to deal with
women and it's been hard to do since
lately too.
So lately since my social skills
tanked over the last nine months,
trauma,
Conga Line of horrific events happened
and I am working on getting the
confidence back through Brazilian
Jujitsu already lost 11 pounds and I'm
starting to feel a lot better. All right,
well just don't go choke out any women.
All right, I'll try to put
them in the triangle. He said
anyways, is there any way,
but martial arts are a great way to
build self esteem from what I've heard
anyways.
Is there any,
is there any way to get rid of the insane
fear I have about women or is it just
15 years of hurt that will
take almost forever an undo?
Thanks and go fuck yourself six ways
from Sunday and good luck with your stand
up. Um, all right, I'll see. You're
only 15. Is that what you're saying?
All right dude. First of all, it's
great you took up Brazilian Jujitsu,
you should know how to
defend yourself and uh,
don't be a cunt about it when
you become a black belt, uh,
use it to save nerds and protect yourself,
but never be a bully.
Um,
and then as far as women,
I would actually try and talk to somebody
about this and I would try to have
more of an open mind because right now
if you're only 15 years old or even if
you're young in your early twenties,
mid twenties, you're basically,
you've got the lottery pick as
far as women goes. All right.
They're all available.
All first round draft picks,
bunch of first round draft
picks just sitting there.
Yeah.
And you know,
depending on when you open your mouth
and start talking to one is when you pick
in the draft, if you know what I
mean. Sooner rather than later.
But I would just talk to
somebody about, um, about,
about some of your issues.
Maybe it's school,
they got some free fucking therapy or
something like that if you're too young to
pay for it.
But,
um,
I dunno,
I would talk to somebody,
I would talk to some of your
guy friends about it. I would,
you know what I would do,
I would openly talk about
your fear of women to,
um, to friends, you know, and I would,
I would sit down with your
mother and just say, listen,
I have major issues with women right now.
And I think some of it stems from a lot
of the negative things that you've said
about them. And I need you to stop doing
that because it's, it's fucking with me.
Don't, don't say that part, but say it in
a nicer way. Um, but if she's, you know,
I dunno,
that's the hardest fucking thing is
because you are born into the religion of
your parents, you know, and,
and to all of their beliefs and
hopefully they have more good than bad,
but they're humans so they're
going to be wrong. And you know,
when you're a little toddler all the
way through like seven, eight years old,
your parents are godlike.
You just think they know everything
and they have all the answers.
They never look unsure.
You do everything that they fucking say.
So a lot of that stuff just
really takes deep root. Like it's,
it's law in your head and then he,
a teenage years,
you start breaking away. You realize
some of his bullshit and let's win.
Some anger can come out
and that type of stuff.
So I would say what you're
going through is normal.
It's just that you may be had an extreme,
a helping of some fucking anti woman shit,
which I can relate to because I did too.
And I had to fight through that shit.
I mean, it took me and get married till
I was 45. I had made your fucking issues.
But uh, it's like anything, look, it,
just use the martial arts thing as a,
a metaphor or a simile.
Whatever the fuck you're supposed to.
Whatever the right terminology is. Look
at you. You did that. You stuck with that.
You lost 11 pounds. You work towards
that. Look at, look at what you're,
you're getting, you're getting positive
results and it hasn't been easy, right?
But You keep showing up,
you get positive results.
I would do the same thing
with your women issues.
I would just start working
on it. Um, you know,
next time a woman comes up and says hello,
don't say I have somewhere to go.
Just say hello back and stay in the
conversation for as long as you can.
And when you feel like
baling, just say, listen,
I'm really shy around women and it's
something that I'm trying to work on.
Just put it out there.
And you know what I guarantee
80% of them are going to say, oh,
you know, when they do that, they're
gonna love it. And next thing you know,
you're out there watching a romantic
comedy with some lady having a good time.
But I would, I would address it sooner
than later. I'm telling you, dude,
it's you literally, it's, you think
it's a mountain. It's, it's a fucking,
it's stepping up onto the curb.
It's all in your head.
And that's totally normal because I would
guess that your fears started when you
were in your mom's godlike
phase of your life.
So you think you think it's
a, hey, what's going on?
Fucking Mount Everest and it requires
the client is wanting podcast is from,
it's a little fucking ant hill and John,
you can do it. All right. I believe in,
you know, good luck, sir. There you go.
It's going to be the 20th
right now. Wait a minute,
I'm on September here.
God dammit
it is the 20th.
The fucking odds.
Are there any ways what's going on?
It's a Bill Barr,
the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
July the 20th,
and I'm actually doing it Sunday night.
Cause A,
whenever you're listening to this fucking
thing, I'm, I'm probably out golfing.
Yes.
Believe in a,
not a guy who already has too many God
damn hobbies with his pathetic drumming
and guitar playing. Um, I don't know.
I've somehow got sucked into that game,
fighting it,
fighting it my entire adult life.
All my friends that all my friends
to a bunch of fucking people I know.
They date day golf. And, uh,
I always viewed it like drinking coffee.
I just didn't like,
I don't know,
I just didn't look like that much fun,
but everyone was completely addicted to
it. You know, I took a sip of fucking,
uh, coffee when I was like eight
years old and it tasted like shit.
Tasted like dirty water and it looked
like dirty water and that's what it tasted
like.
And I know I never,
I never got into it and done
it all my whole adult life.
I just watch all these
people walking around.
They can't start their fucking day
unless they get a cup of this shit.
You know,
all these people talking about people
on crystal meth and addicted to alcohol
and shit like that. I mean, I guess
they're not fucking slurring their speech,
you know,
it doesn't cause them to slap that fucking
wife around or something like that.
So I guess it's kind of harmless.
But I dunno,
I remember this kid when
I worked in a warehouse,
he used to drink like fucking
eight cokes a day, you know,
he'd like sucked down like one
an hour when we were working.
And one day decided to try to quit
cold Turkey and this kid couldn't even
function. He had like this
migraine headache. He lasted
like an hour and a half,
maybe two hours for up until our
first break. And he just finally,
he drank a coke and he just
felt better. So, uh, yeah.
So I avoided that shit.
And uh, I don't know,
I've been kind of worried about losing
my memory and somebody told me if you
actually drink caffeine that
actually helps with Alzheimer's.
I had an Italian meal a few weeks ago and
I drank a shot of espresso or espresso
ever the fuck you say it. And uh,
I dunno, I have to, uh, I know,
I know it was fucking brutal. I got it
over with though. And then someone's like,
no, no, no. I actually read
where it adds to Alzheimer,
Alzheimer's disease. And I was like, you
know what? I don't give a fuck. You know,
none of you are doctors who are
giving me this advice, you know,
it's fucking ridiculous. He might not
like, how many times do you get done that?
You know, you just sit in a bar
and somebody just says that.
Well actually caffeine helps,
uh, helps against a, helps
prevent a Alzheimer's. Uh,
they'd done studies. Oh really? Really?
Do you have any of those studies in front
of you? What the fuck do you do? Huh?
What do you, what do you, what do you,
what does anybody do anymore? Huh?
What are you doing?
Why don't you sit in a fucking cubicle
looking at spreadsheets of the sweatshop
labor. This is how fucked up this
country is right now. As far as like,
I'm really just trying to
buy American made shit. Um,
I actually went on, I got a
couch and I went to this, uh,
this furniture store over here in
the valley and it was, uh, you know,
allegedly American made shit.
So I,
I ordered this couch cause you know,
you don't want to take the one that's
on the floor that everybody's fucking
plopped down on. So I get this
couch, right. So I'm like,
when I asked before I bought the couch,
you know,
cause I want to buy American
made shit made by Americans.
You know what I mean? Get this
fucking country going again. Well,
like we can't make a couch.
You know,
we've made the best look and fucking cars
of all goddamn time before we started
being cheap motherfuckers about it.
All right.
We went to the moon and we
faked going to the moon.
I don't know what the fuck we did.
Okay, but it was, it was impressive.
We can make a goddamn couch. Okay. I
asked the guy, where's the couch made?
He says, it's made in Pasadena. Long
story short is I have a problem.
I end up having a problem
with the upholstery that they
put on the fucking thing.
So that was when I actually know, and
I've had to send the stupid couch back.
I actually learned of their process.
This is what they do.
They do make the couch in Pasadena,
they build the damn thing,
but when they put the upholstery on it,
they actually,
that part of the job,
they shipped it down to like Honduras.
Okay. Think about that. They build it
in Pasadena. I live over here in la.
All right. And they fucking
ship it to Honduras. To, to,
to have the, uh, the, uh,
what did the upholstery put on it and
then they ship it back to America.
So my thing is like how fucking cheap
is the Goddamn labor down there that
that's, that that's financially
a better way to go. You know
the fuck am I talking about golf here?
I'm talking about fucking shipping
couches to Honduras. I don't know.
It's late at night here and I'm trying
not to fucking scream and yell cause uh,
cause my neighbors are sleeping here.
Um, yeah. So anyway, so I've uh,
taken up golf and a,
I still refuse to take it seriously.
Although I did go out and buy
a little tiger woods outfit,
you know, I don't know.
I just didn't want to go down there
looking like a Douche, you know,
like the frat boy. I figured if
I dress nicely, even if I suck,
maybe I look like, you know, I'm
having a bad day or something.
So, uh, anyways, I'm golfing right
now. That's what the fuck I'm doing.
And uh, I missed that. Oh,
a British open yesterday
where a Tom Watson,
Tom Watson, I thought the
guy was like dead, you know,
even though our in Palmer still alive,
this fucking guy is like 59 years old.
He almost won the British open,
but then he didn't,
which is typical of golf. Oh
my God, something's great.
Great's going to happen
and then it doesn't.
And then you watch somebody choke
in front of their entire family.
I still haven't gotten over the math
master's, you know, even though, uh,
with Kenny Perry said his name, he's
one another. Uh, he wants to see,
I don't know what the fuck you want,
but he didn't get a green jacket.
I can tell you that. Can fucking tell you
that. What am I talking about this week?
Hey, this is the deal.
All right. You know,
it's a deal cause I started
the sentence off with, hey,
I was trying to get your attention
there. Uh, I'm going to be at the, uh,
the comedy works in Denver,
Colorado on a Thursday,
Friday and Saturday of this week.
It's one of my favorite clubs out there.
And I also want to thank everybody
who came out to see my show. Um,
a week ago,
I'm at the punchline.
My had a great time as a first time I was
onstage headlining since the middle of
May because I was being a little fancy
fucking dude. There's Jimmy Norton says,
uh, make it a movie or sitting
around waiting to do my 11 lines,
however the fuck you want to look at it.
But I'm going to say it in the positive
way. I was making a movie and a,
I was a little, a little rusty, kind of
found my, I was a little, little, uh,
it's a little messy, but
uh, I got through it,
but I was a by the second
show is back on my game.
So I'm really looking forward to this
and if you guys haven't been listened to
my podcast,
um,
I am going to be doing another special
and it looks like it's going to be in
December and it looks like
if everything works out,
I'm going to be taping it
in San Francisco. So, um,
I am going to be in a theater or a
comedy club near you from here till then,
from right now until then
that I say that correctly. Um,
I kind of have a bit of a,
it starts getting going basically
right at the end of August and I'm just
hardcore September, October,
November and half of December.
And then I'm going to take the thing,
I am going to be hardcore on the road
like the old days when I wasn't making any
money.
So I had to go out like three,
four times a fucking month and then
do a bunch of spots in the city.
I'm going to be doing it like that and uh,
I'm looking forward to it.
I'm going to try to eat healthy on
the road. These are my goals now.
Am I going to do it? Who? To?
Who the fuck knows? All right.
I'm gonna try not to drink when I'm
on the road and try to do some yoga.
I'm going to try to fucking do
some cardio, do some pull ups,
get myself in shape physically and uh,
not look like a bloated jackass. That's
the last thing you want to fucking do.
You don't want to sweat and you want to
look like a bloated jackass during your
special. And, and then thirdly, you
want to be fucking hilarious, but that,
that is the, uh, that is the order.
Number one. You do not want to sweat we,
you balls. It's no big deal. They'll
throw some laughter in there.
Maybe that'll sweeten it up
or maybe they'll just play
it once and people forget
about it. But if you're
pouring fucking sweat people,
people remember that Shit, you
know? Now why would you, no,
you don't fucking, you don't do stand up.
All right, I'm a little out of it here.
Uh, all right, what do we got here? Um,
let's get on with the questions here.
Oh and if you knew my
podcast, welcome, um,
my joke every week that I
only have like 14 listeners,
but I gotta admit I was at the,
uh,
when I was at the punchline on Monday
punchline in San Francisco, somebody, uh,
somebody yelled out Pau Gasol cause they
wanted to see my impression as I was
talking about, I did one here
on the podcast. So before
I just launched into it,
I asked the people in the crowd, hey,
how many you guys listen to my podcast?
And it was literally like
three quarters of the crowds.
So I was kind of blown away by that.
So I think I might be up to
about 27 listeners, their people.
Um, anyways, so, uh, let's get
on with the podcast here. Uh,
last week I was talking about all
the celebrities who died and uh,
and how all these morons,
when Ed Mcmahon died and
then Farah died and then, uh,
Michael Jackson died. People, what do
they say? Oh, there you go. You know,
bad things, common tree, you know,
you fucking commentaries and then Billy
Mays dies, right? And then fucking, uh,
what's his face fucking died earlier
that month jerking off he dies,
right?
So that's five.
So you know what some fucking
jackass sends me this email.
He was half joking around.
He goes, you know, he goes,
I'm one of those guys who actually says
all the time that bad things come in
threes. And I actually put
up on my Facebook when those
three celebrities dies,
when they died,
I wrote bad things come in three.
But then he mentioned that
Karl Malden died. He goes,
so technically that six.
So that's three and three.
So I am right.
Really?
Yeah.
That why isn't,
why isn't it bad things come and six you
people are with the bad things come in
through you guys.
You're out of your fucking minds.
Okay,
bad things come in threes.
So then what if somebody else
dies and it goes up to seven,
then you keep your fucking mouth shut
until two more people die and you're going
to see you there. There you
go. It comes back around again.
So you guys just basically,
you basically open your mouth when
whatever bad shit has been happening is
divisible by three to
prove your fucking point.
Okay.
You know,
I could say bad things come at eight and
just wait for the eighth bad thing to
fucking happen and then rattle them off.
Okay.
They don't come in three bad things
just continue to fucking happen,
which is why they have ice
cream and alcohol, you know?
So you can do fun shit while
you're waiting for the neck,
the next bad thing to happen.
Okay.
You know, we had a heat wave out here
there. That's seven bad fucking things.
How, what do you where
you were fucking old lady.
What kind of a fucking human book kind
of a man says that shit. I'm all right,
let's move on to some other stuff.
I know like I was just joking.
The guy who sent me the email in six,
but you know,
if I don't take it seriously then I
don't get emotional about it and then the
podcast isn't funny.
All right.
And then I lose a listener like that one
woman from a fucking couple months ago.
I never heard from her again or her
alleged friends who are listening.
So anyways,
uh,
which really affected the overall value
of this podcast because I'm actually
doing this to get to a certain number
and then I'm going to go corporate and
then I'm going to sell it just like these
fucking cons, who start the, my space,
these, the social, uh, social networks,
whatever the fuck you call them,
what they really are as they're basically
clubs on the Internet. You know, like,
I've never believe it or not,
I was never into the club scene.
I know it's hard to believe that I
didn't put on Cologne and go, all right,
maybe I did it a couple of times,
but I failed so horrifically,
and I've always said, one of my strengths
in life is I've known what I sucked at.
Okay. And going to the night
at the Roxbury things is, uh,
not something I was never good at.
Skews me. I need to drink here.
All right,
that's gross.
You don't want to hear anybody chewing
gum or fucking take a sip of anything,
but you know, it's hot as fuck out
here. I was playing drums all day.
I was actually playing with other
human beings, if you can believe it.
It's a whole different kind of drumming.
Um,
you know when you play by yourself and
you do whatever the fuck you want and you
screw up, there's nobody looking
over their shoulder. Like really?
You said you could play drums there.
There's nobody looking at you like that.
So it was a whole different
fucking level. Um, anyways,
I wasn't of sound, but the social
networks say there, they're like clubs,
you know what I mean?
Where you got the new hot club and all
the cool kids who go in there and then
all the nerds show up and the bridge
and tunnel crowd and all that shit.
And then everybody took off to Facebook.
That's what the fuck happened.
And then all the nerds went over there
and then all the cool kids went over to
Twitter and now all the nerds have
fallen them over there. And it just,
it's going to be never
fucking ending. So, uh,
that's why I'm still here on my space.
I like it. It's a quiet bar now.
You know, they can put the game on.
I could sit here, sip on my drink,
having a good fucking time. Dot.
All these crazy kids, you know,
it's like a dive. That's why I like my
space. It's like a dive bar right now,
you know? Now. Okay. Maybe it isn't.
Maybe I'm just a fucking loser.
It really is just a vast wasteland here.
I'm not even gonna lie to you. I
just, it's just whores and musicians.
That's all that's left here. Um,
and one lonely comedian. All right,
let's get to some feedback here. This is
from a woman, uh, from a couple of weeks,
weeks ago when I was trashing that
Carrie Underwood song. Um, she said,
I am a woman and I've recently become
a regular listener to your podcast.
I was listening to your July 6th
podcast and laughed uncontrollably.
I actually liked,
I actually liked that Carrie Underwood
song and cannot argue with the things you
said.
The two piece combination to the
cabbage comment was fricking hilarious.
Just thought you should hear it from
a woman. That was awesome. All right,
well you know what, I should, well
thank you very much. I appreciate that.
And just because you brought that up,
I'm going to actually give you the history
behind the two piece combination to
the cabbage actually where I heard
that it was actually a slide.
I gave a variation of it.
I was on my way to do a standup Gig in
one of the outer boroughs in New York.
Um,
and I was with somebody and they were
pissed at somebody else and they were
saying how they were going to kill him
and they were not joking and they were
going off and just like,
you know this motherfucker,
this is my fucking dad.
I'm going to fucking Bubba ball his shit.
And he was basically,
and I'm looking at the Duke because
he really, you know, you know,
some people just don't,
I'm going to fucking kill this guy.
This guy was dead serious.
So it was kind of an awkward moment in,
I'm just sorta like nod.
And you know,
trying to act like I hear
somebody everyday tell me
that they're going to kill
another human being.
And uh,
he was talking about he was going
to shoot him in the head. And uh,
he, the way he put it, he's the,
granted I hadn't laughed up to this point.
He said he was gonna
shoot him in the head.
And then there was this awkward silence
and then he just says a throw away,
throw away line.
He just,
he said two beans to the cabbage
and it was like a half second pause.
And I just started roaring laughing,
which got him laughing and then
we were just fucking laughing.
And then he kept trying to say, no, I'm
serious son, as he's fucking laughing.
And it was just one of those great fucking
moments and nobody ended up getting
killed at the end of it. And it was
just something that's just stuck.
It's not the beans, it's the
cabbage. This just something,
there's something about when you do damage
to somebody's head that it literally,
cabbage is the, I don't know why it's
just perfect. It's just perfect. So, uh,
that's how I got the cabbage reference.
And, uh, of course everyone was remade.
I even tell you the borough, say
right there, that's how you do it.
Where the fuck am I kidding?
If anything ever happened?
And they dragged me and they wouldn't
have to do good cop, bad cop,
all they'd have to do is slam
the door. And I'd be like,
okay, we were driving. Oh,
the lie. And, um, anyways, all right,
here's a fucked up new story for you. Ah,
Shit. God Damn. Piece of shit computer.
Um, or maybe it's the person
operating it. All right, here we go.
Here's a fucked up new story that
somebody sent me, a Lacrosse woman.
Now this is not a woman
who plays Lacrosse.
It's a woman from a town
evidently called Lacrosse.
And this story is so fucked up that I
actually researched it on the internet.
And by research,
I mean,
I did a quick search and I clicked on
the first story and it agreed with me and
therefore it became fact. So with
that background, let's read the story.
All right? Yeah. I lacrosse
woman, a woman from Lacrosse, uh,
is accused of stabbing her boyfriend
Tuesday after she caught him watching
pornography and masturbating
according to Lacrosse police reports.
Okay. She caught him watching
pornography and masturbating,
so she allegedly stabbed him.
Uh,
Rachel Ferrara,
23 found her 24 year old
boyfriend inside her home.
Um,
the couple argued and four are accused
the man of explicative being a,
an explicative cheater being a fucking
cheater because evidently he was
masturbating to pornography.
Uh,
she evidently punched him twice in
the abdomen, kicked him in the groin,
four Ferrara,
then back the man into the kitchen,
which I know a lot of
people like, oh my God. Oh,
women couldn't back them in into the,
yes,
she can because we can not lay a hand on.
So when you go psycho,
that's what you do. You back into the
room going, honey, relax, relax, crazy.
He'd take a couple of more, you know, put
you, if you try to do the George for me,
you know, George Foreman covers
up his body late in his career.
You've got one forum soda in front of
your face and the other one below you.
It's almost like you're starting to
cross your arms to do that run DMC thing,
but you start midway, you
know, like the end of chips.
Um, anyways, God bless you if
he got that joke. All right.
Uh, so for hour then back,
the man is to the kitchen.
She grabbed a five inch serrated knife
and slashed his arms before stabbing him
in the abdomen. According to reports, uh,
she reportedly refused as attempts
to calm down, calm her down,
and she screamed at him to leave.
The man drove himself to Gunderson blood,
a medical center where he
was treated and release. Uh,
the woman Ferrara was arrested on charges
of disorderly conduct while armed and
recklessly endangering safety.
She's expected later today in
Lacrosse County Circuit Court.
So the man who sent me this said really
disorderly conduct while armed and
recklessly endangering safety.
If I as a guy went and
stabbed my girlfriend in the
abdomen because she had a
vibrator in her Twat,
I would get charged with attempted
murder and possibly rape.
But I guess that's why we
make a dollar more an hour.
Oh Shit that I just steal one of
your jokes. Oh, well sincerely.
And then he names the name of a
comedian who's known for stealing jokes.
Um, yeah, that is a kind of a
light charge. Wouldn't you say?
You know,
I'm not sitting here saying that she
actually did any of this shit because I
understand that when I know what a
legend means. Okay. But my thing is what,
you know, if she did do this
shit, which they're trying to, uh,
prove disorderly conduct while armed
and recklessly endangering safety.
Now what does that mean to you guys?
Okay.
If I told you I was arrested of disorderly
conduct while armed and recklessly
endangering safety, you
know what, that would me.
That would mean I'm at a gun range and
I'm shit faced and I didn't properly
Holser my,
my weapon after I shot at a paper target.
That's kind of what it seems like,
you know,
or maybe I'm doing something,
I'm trying to shoot a bottle of rocket
out of my asshole or I don't know.
I don't know what, you know what I
mean, but that we would, you know,
if I told you I got
arrested for that Shit,
you wouldn't thought that I
fucking stab somebody, you know,
slashed their arms and then fucking
stabbed him. You know, I, I,
I don't understand.
When is the world going to
understand that whoever is a knife,
if they stabbed somebody,
you know,
regardless of their sex
that is attempted murder,
isn't it? It's fucking unreal.
I got to tell you something. Uh,
I'm going to go see that movie coming
out. Um, I think it's called orphan.
I don't know. What would that little scary
girl in it where they, they, they uh,
they rescue this girl like
some fucking psycho pit bull,
like the one that I have. Um, oh my God,
she had a fucking dream the other night
and fuck you, you dude from England.
All right.
You fast forward through this shit.
I don't give a fuck do
from a couple of weeks ago.
He says he can't stand
my stories about it.
I'm going to fucking tell when
every week just to annoy you.
This is how crazy shelter dogs are.
My fucking dog is lying there.
And I'm about, and I'm like, you know,
drifting off to sleep and all
of a sudden I'm hearing like,
or or
hi, and it's like seeping into my
dream. You know, I'm fucking, I dunno,
talking to some whore in my dream and all
of a sudden she turns into like a bear
or some shit, right? So I
fucking wake up. I'm like,
fuck on a dream is then I look over
and there's my damn dog sound asleep,
move in. One of his paws
gone her doing that shit.
So I don't know what the
fuck to do, right? You know,
you're not supposed to awake,
uh,
sleeping sleepwalk and human being.
What do I do with fucking psycho pitbull
that's evidently having words with
somebody in a goddamn dream. So I
decided to wake her up. I was like, Cleo,
Cleo,
cleo.
And then she immediately just sort of
woke up and then looked at me and just
started wagging her tail.
Like, oh, hey, how's it going?
And then just put her
head back down again.
Like all that shit just didn't happen.
It's just fucking
the fucking things. Nuts. All right, let's
get back to the, uh, let's get picked to,
I want to see that movie,
that movie a orphan there. Um,
which is, uh, you know, it's just,
there's something about women
when they're the bad guy. It, I,
it's extra scary to me. You know what
I'm talking about, a guy being a maniac.
I know. You just look at it, ah,
fuck that guy. Fuck am I, you know,
whatever. I drop, kick them. You know,
you just think shit like that for the
most part. But there's something about,
I don't know if it's, they've
always freaked me out and
for some reason, you know,
I was thinking about that. How like
women, you know, women being the, uh,
the Michael Myers to me is way
more scary than the guy. Um,
and I remember when I wave back and
like 82 or 83 when I first got cable,
um, I was watching late night
and I can't even, you know, I,
I really feel bad for people of this
generation who have just grown up with
cable.
You have no idea how
fucking insane cable is.
You have no idea. We had three
networks to uhs and that was it.
And nobody cursed, no
titties, no nothing. It was,
it was unbelievable.
Unbelievable when that shit came out.
So anyways,
so I'm watching late night and I was
watching this movie and I looked it up on
youtube.
It's actually the movie
is called curtains and uh,
it has one of the most bizarre
fucked up scenes. You know,
I went back and I watched it. It
really didn't hold up over time. Um,
but back in the day it really fucking
freaked me out. Um, it basically,
there's a scene in that movie curtains
where there's a girl who's out on a pond
and she's fucking take it.
I can't even explain it for,
I forget cause I haven't seen the
movie in so long. The clip I watched,
she's basically uncovering snow
and you think it's a dead body,
but it's a doll underneath.
And then she's holding it up.
The doll has a weird look on her face
and then there's sort of cutting to these
fucking ice skates slowly in slow motion,
just beginning to skate across
the pond towards this girl.
And of course she has no idea that this
fucking thing is coming towards her and
they just show it from a distance
and it just looks like a person.
And as it gets closer and closer,
it just,
it's this fucking psycho f I think
it's a woman, I can't even remember,
but it looks like a
woman's got a female face,
like a which face with long hair and she's
skating like she speed skate and then
she pulls out like this fucking sickle.
I can't exceed. It's fucked up,
right? I mean, I dunno dude.
I went from Barney Miller to that.
That was,
that's what it was like to have
no cable and then to have that,
and I'm like literally 12, 13 fucking
years old. The movie's called curtains.
Just look it up.
Um,
it's the only part of the movie
probably worth worth watching.
You can actually watch the clip and
when you're a, when you're there,
there's another clip that you have to
watch that kind of ties into this whole
thing where a women, you know,
when they do violent shit,
they just don't get charged with
the same stuff that a guy does.
And if you really feel that there's no
justice in the world ever when it comes
to females physically doing stuff to guys,
I have a video for you and I cannot
take credit for this youtube video.
Um,
this isn't even youtube video of the week.
It's not youtube video of the
month as far as I'm concerned.
This is youtube video of the fucking year.
This is what I want you guys to
Google right here. Go whatever.
Go on Youtube and search tough
talk in college girl. All right,
somebody sent me this clip
is unbelievable. Okay.
And toughest spelled t u f F.
Okay.
And it basically and resolve balls.
The classic scenario,
the hot chick in the bikini,
there's some guy hitting on her.
She uh,
starts giving him shit back.
He gives her shit and then she
throws drink in his face, you know,
and then turns around and walks away.
Cause that's what you do when you throw
a fucking drink in somebody's face.
You just walk away.
Yeah.
You know,
now as a guy,
I feel bad for guys or whoever's fucking
listen to this right now and you're not
near a fucking computer cause
you're really just need to watch it.
You've really need to watch it because
in a perfect world this is what you'd be
able to do as a guy.
All right.
No I don't. I have to talk about this
video. I, I, you know, spoiler alert,
I'm going to tell you
what the fuck happens.
So if you want to hit pause and fucking
watched the video or if you want to
listen to me talk about
the video and this is,
I'm babbling right now to give
you that opportunity. Okay?
Cause I'm going to ruin
what the fuck happens. Okay,
I'm going to talk about it in three,
two, one. Alright, here we go.
So she throws the fucking drink in his
face and just turns around and walks away.
Okay. Cause that's what happens
in movies. Nothing ever happens.
And not to mention,
if you ever do go to make a move on some
girl who does some shit like that to
you, there's usually a couple of
bouncers there to choke you out.
Basically the scenarios that are
outside of the pool, you know,
I can't defend the kid who got
the drink thrown in his face.
He definitely kind of looks like a, he
could be a bit of a Douche, but whatever.
He's got the balls to walk up to this
hot chick that back in the day when I was
his age, I wouldn't have the balls to
walk up to. So I give the kid props. Okay.
But he does have his sunglasses dangling
from his ears and hanging underneath
his chin. So right there, that Douche
level of that guy's pretty fucking high,
so whatever. So she throws the fucking
drink in his face and just walks away.
You know,
she doesn't give a shit that he's got to
go home and change or he's got to stand
there and be sticky in 80 degree
weather outside the fucking the pool.
So he immediately,
you know,
takes a half a pause and then just fucking
walks up to the girl and she's still
trying to act tough. She's
like, what? You know,
you know like white girls because they've
watched reality TV now know how to act
ghetto. She's like what? And throws the
empty plastic cup down on the ground.
Like she's going to do something.
All right. And the dude,
I thought he was going to wind
up in blast or in the face.
So at this point I'm watching it with
one eye cause I don't give a fuck what a
girl does. You never want to see her get
hit, fucking closed fisted. It's, it's,
it's just, it's ugly even though
she threw the drink. But the dude
fucking just, I had to watch
it twice to see what he does.
He does a fucking leg sweep that,
that I swear to God,
he could've beat one of the Gracies
with one of his this, he just,
it's like the girl standing up
and then she is not, he just went,
I can't believe like from her knees down,
both those parts of her legs didn't
fly off like a mortar hit him.
That's how fucking he just fucking,
I'm at literally standing up
acting in and out again. Huh.
This is like when I told the Rosebowl
story back in the day, right.
He literally just fucking leg sweeps her
and she just goes back down the ground
and she
hits the back of her head on the concrete
and that's the part we like, Ooh,
not good. Funny until the back
of the head hits the concrete.
But she immediately goes like,
ah,
screaming basically sounding the alarm
for all the guys to come and rescue her,
which they kind of don't. They kind
of all stand up like, hey dude, whoa,
what's going on? You know, and uh, I know,
you know, why did I try to describe the,
I can't do justice. You have to see
this tough talk in college girl,
just Google that and spelled tough.
T U F F and I swear to God,
like I said,
I don't advocate hitting a woman.
And I think women should respect that
rather than take advantage of it.
And I really think if you take a full
drink and you throw it in somebody's face,
you're really taking advantage of that.
A man should never hit a woman. Okay.
And uh, I really have to be honest with
you. If the guy punched her in the face,
I would have said that he was a Douche.
But there's something about a
leg sweep that it had a, uh,
a gentleman quality to
it. You know, in fact,
that's the comment I left under
the first time the video was up.
It was taken down,
but the comment I left was
leg sweep equals gentlemen,
I gotta be honest with you.
I've seen girls get punched.
I've seen them get slapped. Okay.
I've seen a guy, Shaker girl,
I've seen a dude, choker girl. None of
this I advocate, but I've seen all that.
I have never seen somebody go
for the legs sweep. And it was,
it was uh, it was uh, it was
surprising. You know what I mean?
It's like when you see a movie and you
think you know how it's going to end,
like oh Jesus. And then the hero comes
in and the white horse and then no, no,
Leonardo Dicaprio gets popped
in the fucking elevator
and you're like, Holy Shit.
Holy Shit. I didn't see
that common. That's what,
that's what that fucking
leg sweep was like.
It was like seeing DiCaprio get popped
in the departed fucking phenomenal
youtube video of the year.
Why don't we have that?
That's a new segment here on uh,
my Monday morning podcasts. Let's,
let's have nominees. Okay. Cause
when they nominate the Oscars,
it's usually like two, three months ahead
of time. That's all I have in December.
You guys just remind me,
we will have the nominees for
youtube video of the year for me.
Okay. Uh, that movie is
like the equivalent to the,
uh,
I'm not going to say there will be blood.
It's more like no country for old men
and all that kid should just had a bowl
cut and just not blinked when he fucking
did it. And, and that, that I, I
would have bought it on DVD. Um,
all right. So there you go. Okay.
Was that misogynistic enough?
We always have to have that moment
in this fucking podcast. All right,
let's wind it down here with the questions
because it's getting late. And, uh,
I gotta get up early here cause I have
a tee time. A whole new stopped on the,
all right. Questions. Um, hey Mr. Byrd,
how's that for making you feel fucking
old. It did, it did make me feel it.
All right. All right. Um, I was just
wondering what your thoughts on we're on,
why people are so easily offended,
especially by foul language.
I thought you might have some insight
here as someone who uses the word cunt and
fuck quite regularly, um, hey,
guilty as charged. Um, maybe, um,
it has something to do with the
fact that I live in the south,
but it seems like you dropped
the f bomb here. Oh, I see.
What you're saying? Uh, maybe it has to
do with the fact that I live in the south,
that if you drop the f bomb
here or tell someone, um,
tell someone with all,
all the fucking padding,
why didn't I enlarge this? I am
the worst reader. I'm sorry guys.
Let me start this again.
Ah,
maybe has something to do with
the fact that I live in the south,
but it seems like if you
drop the f bomb here or tell,
tell something to someone without all
the fucking padding and they just lose
their shit.
And do you think this has something to
do with the Pussy fication of America?
Or do most people just grow up in a
household where ball busting or do most
people not grow up in a household where
a ball busting is commonplace? Um,
I dunno, you know, when I go across to
America, I don't see a lot of pussies.
I see a lot of psychos. I just think
in general that, um, this country has,
you know,
just really become corporate and they
cast a wide net there always commercial
fishing.
So they're trying not to offend people.
So a lot of the shows on TV as
sort of been a dumbed down I think,
but in general,
I mean,
I live in America and I say
fucking content all the time
as do all of my friends.
And uh,
there you go.
So I'm defining America by how I behave.
Um, I dunno. I think, I think
certain people grow up, uh,
with ball busting and other people don't.
And the reality is everybody has
a different line. And I think the,
the real thing is that people who
get offended are way more organized.
Um, and they complain and they write
letters and people who don't give a fuck,
don't give a fuck enough to write a letter
to say, I don't give a fuck. You know,
so there you go.
Did you guys hear that Burp?
That was one of those internal burps that
I heard in my head and I can't tell if
that was out loud. All right. Um, all
right, let's move onto the next one.
Hey, Bill. Big Fan. Love your community.
And you purchased a fucking Hilarious,
thank you very much. Uh, I appreciate
that you're doing for free. Thank you.
Anyways,
I have a question for you.
When a comedian such as
yourself records a CD or a DVD,
is that a one time shot or are you able
to reshoot if you are unhappy with the
show? Um, it all depends.
Um, I can for the most part, yeah.
If you do like a standup special,
you do a,
you do at least two shows.
I was watching a guy recently on HBO
hype and his special and he was talking
about working somewhere in Texas and he
was going to do four shows and from the
four shows he was going to
put together the special,
but for the most part you do at least two.
So this is how it's worked with me.
I did a CD called emotionally unavailable,
which is available on iTunes.
Um, I really need a whore out my
shit more too, by the way. Um,
but how I did that was,
I taped that at the laff house in
Philadelphia and I was doing four shows to
Friday and two Saturday
and I taped all the shows.
I listen back to all the shows and I
just liked the second show Saturday night
and I liked it and I got heckled and there
was some awkward moments in it and it
just sounded like a show.
And what I liked about the old school
comedy albums that I used to listen to
when I was growing up as
you really felt like, um,
you were Kinda in the nightclub when you
were listening and that type of thing.
And it just, I don't know,
with all those pro tool stuff,
you can really make something sound
really slick. And I, you know,
I think I wrote that in the liner notes.
Wow. I'm really going back a long way.
I can,
the liner notes actually wrote like,
I didn't kind of want to splice
together our performance.
That never really
happened, you know? So, uh,
and then the other half was I
was fucking lazy and it was true.
I wasn't gonna go through four hours of
fucking audio and just listening to me
do the same. I just couldn't fucking
do it. Sounds like, you know what?
I like that second show Saturday.
So that's how I did that.
That one on the Hbo one,
when I did my half hour,
there was a two tapings and my
first show went really well.
So I knew I had a good special.
And then I came out the second one and
the second one I was even more loose and
that one just went ridiculously great.
And afterwards the director was like,
you know what?
I think that second one was the one
other than this one little joke.
So why don't we just take one
little joke from the first one,
stick that in and the rest will be the
second show. And I said, works for me.
So that's how that one went together.
And why do I do this was only one show.
Um, that one. And that
was because of the budget.
Uh, we kind of waited a little too long
to get a theater and we had to spend more
money than we thought.
And then in the end we only had
the budget to do one of them. So,
um, what you see is what you get on
that one. That was just one, one take.
And I left out some tags and that type
of shit and it was kind of freaking me
out in the beginning of the special.
Um, if you look closely in my eyes,
you'll see it a couple of times.
Um, but then I was just like,
well fuck it. No one's going to know
that I missed the tags, you know,
this is the special bill. Why don't
you get present and fucking deliver it?
So I just, you know, um, yeah,
that's how I did that one. But,
um, yeah, basically speaking, yeah,
you don't just do one unless
you have no fucking budget.
Are you fucked up your budget
or something like that.
So this one that I do and uh,
San Diego,
San Diego and San Francisco, I
am going to be doing too. Um,
and also I'm going to be doing a
bunch of fucking roadwork before, uh,
before I come up to it. So I'm
going to be extra ready. Um,
and I actually learned something
last time when I did an hour,
basically when I did my half hour for
HBO was on the road doing 50 minutes.
So to do a half hour was a joke.
It's kind of like if you're doing cardio
for 15 minutes and then one day he did
30 be easy.
So,
but what I wasn't doing when I trained
for the hour was when I was doing the
hour I was doing right
about an hour. So, um,
it felt like more work than
doing the half hour. Um,
so this time when I go through,
I'm going to be doing at least an
hour and 10 an hour and 15 minutes.
When I'm on stage, especially
September, um, September,
October, November, I'm, unless
I'm doing three shows at night,
I won't do that cause I don't
want to back it up at a, you know,
I get actually I am actually really
against doing more than an hour on stage.
I think it becomes a, you
know, people are just like,
all right and we got it. You're funny.
Or we have to go to work tomorrow. Okay.
My face hurts.
It's like you're overselling.
I always feel like when you do more
than an hour, you kind of overselling.
Although I did an hour and 13, I just
uploaded that one from San Francisco,
not where you guys can listen,
where I can listen to it. And uh,
it actually holds together.
I think maybe a,
I just wasn't in shape enough to do it.
Um, but I just, I don't know. I just find,
you know, once you get like
an hour, hour and 15 and it's
like, Dude, enough. Enough.
All right. Jesus Christ. Bill,
how many fucking different ways you're
gonna answer that? All right. Overrated.
Underrated. And then I'm going
to get out of here. Uh, okay.
Underrated. Uh, Bill
Burke. Thank you. Lewis.
Black Don Cheadle, Samuel Jackson
Beer. Real hip hop in parentheses,
common.
Most def to lead
Kweli Kweli I don't know
who the fuck that is.
That he is underrated and I have
no idea who that is. Kanye West.
Okay. How about the fuck is
Kanye West underrated? Uh,
overrated.
Everything on B e t m t v V h one
Sonia Sato mayor. I don't know who that
is. Barack Obama, United States military.
I was a marine for five years.
Uh,
J fucking Cutler is still
won't help the bears for shit.
Um, you don't actually reminds me, you
know, something. I finally, you know, I,
I've gotten into some sort
of old school like a hip hop,
but I just don't know what
the fuck to listen to. Um,
I've kind of talking like late eighties,
early nineties.
Anything pre biggie if he can,
if you've got some shit. Um,
you know,
and not just obvious shit that like Kool
moe Dee that they played on like MTV,
like some underground shit like this. Just
stuff that I always hear. I'll be like,
oh, you know, I kinda liked
this guy, the big, oh,
he was in leaders of the new school or
a WHO's that group Eric sermon was in,
you know, like if you know any of that
shit, if you're going to let me know,
give me the heads up on that.
I'd like,
I'd like to download some of that shit
cause uh, I dunno, I'm into it now.
I'm trying to play drums to it and it's
fun again for a challenging. All right.
Another underrated comics, uh,
overrated. Here's an overrated ones.
This is what kind of an obscure one,
a comp overrated comics who do a
visual bit during their specials,
um,
and acknowledged to the live audience.
How funny it is that the
CD listeners are left out.
You made a funny face. We get it. Yeah.
You know what? I think I've done that.
Or You,
you're recording a CD and you do a visual
joke and then you comment how everyone
at home. I wasn't going to understand that
joke. Oh, we're all doing it. All right.
Um, last thing asked bill. Hey,
bill just started listening to
uninformed last week. Um, and that's my,
uh, show radio show that I do
on a Sirius satellite radio,
Sirius Xm, whatever the fuck
they call it. And you know what?
Somebody just sent me a fucking
a thing here on where they
hell you could listen to those
bill, read this. You Fag.
This is like the new thing everyone's
doing because at one guy uninformed,
here we go.
Uh,
all right, here's where you can listen
to all the uninformed shows that,
that I've done with Joe
to Rosa, uh, for free. Um,
you can on mini mini,
nova.com.
M I, N I, mini, m, I, N. I, Nova,
N O v, a, all lowercase, no spaces.com.
Uh,
there you go.
You can listen to all of them and we're
going to start doing them again. Uh,
we had one here in July. I don't even
want to fuck. They even put it out.
Fucking disappointing. How disorganized
we go with that Shell. But anyways,
let's get to ask bill here.
Bill, just start a list to
uninformed. We could go. Um,
I downloaded a package of
all the shows done to date,
hence the ancient reference anyways.
Uh, you oh cause I said no XM.
Uh,
anyway,
you mentioned a while ago that you
were really socially awkward as a kid.
I'd love to hear how you overcame that.
I dropped out of high school at 16,
and it seems the more
time I spent the loan,
the harder it gets to inject myself into
any situation that involves other human
beings. I'm now 21, apparently
and adult, but anytime I have to,
uh, have to do a task that may involve
other people, it's a real problem.
Even simple things like taking out
the garbage or going grocery shopping,
make me shake and sweat.
My situation is probably
more severe than yours was,
but I'd love to hear
any advice, uh, to uh,
to overcome this nonsense. Um, all right.
Uh, okay. Well, all right, where
can I start with that shit?
This is all right. Here's how
bad mine was. I was literally,
I would like be at an ATM and if someone
was standing behind me and I had two
transactions,
I would only do one and I would get out
of line for fear that the person behind
me,
the second I started the
second transaction would
literally beat the shit out of
me.
Okay.
Now all this shit is going on in my
head because that's how it worked in my
family growing up. You know, if you
took too much time, like seeing,
I have a bunch of brothers,
so we ended up fist fighting.
But until you verbalize it out loud,
you don't realize how fucking
ridiculous it is. And uh,
so I don't know what did I do? I
basically, while to become a comedian,
I was in college at the time and what I
did was I knew that I could barely give
a book report without
my face turned beet red.
So what I did was I just
started taking classes,
classes where I knew I'd have
to get up in front of the class.
And the more I did it, the more I
enjoyed it and the more it just,
it felt awesome. So
what I would do is, um,
I dunno, uh, I get out a piece of
paper, write out what your fear is.
Like what, what are you, what are
you thinking is going to happen?
So that's another thing too,
man.
You'll spend your whole life cowering
over this great fear that only exists in
your fucking head.
And I swear to God,
and that is most times it's just for some
shit that happened when you were a kid
and your brain was foreman,
how it was going to view the world.
And you just saw some shit or some shit
happened to you at the wrong fucking
time and then that shit just becomes law
in your head as like a five year old,
you know,
and you'll literally 21 years old making
dis fearful decisions of a five year
old and a believe me, do what I did
that. And I can tell you this, you know,
you're young enough, we, it's
Kinda easy to undo that shit,
but if you wait later in life,
like I kind of did it with a lot of stuff.
What it is,
is that little seed of a fucked up thought
kind of grows into this big fucking
oak tree that you got to hack
down. So what I would do is, uh,
you know, um, I dunno, what the
fuck can you do? I don't know what,
I don't know what you do for
a living. I would, you know,
try to be more social at work.
Try to shoot the shit,
uh, get involved in something. If you're
good at sports, join a softball league.
If you play an instrument,
start jamming with other people.
You got to get yourself into the
mix of people and uh, you know,
it's Kinda like a, you know, I knew
somebody who really sucked at driving,
you know, and they were freaking
out about it. And just so you know,
the more they did it, it's just
like stand up. If you swear to God,
I would never show you guys these tastes.
But if you could ever see video of
when I first started doing standup,
when I got on stage,
I was so fucking nervous.
I never stopped moving the
whole time I was on stage.
I will get on stage and I would just pace
the entire time that would be pouring
sweat.
It's like,
it's almost like a performance art or
some avant garde cause it doesn't even
fucking make sense when you watch it.
I said,
I can't believe I ever even got
any laughs. But as he, you know,
years went by and the more shows I did,
the more comfortable I got,
the more presence I could be.
And that's basically how to do it.
But don't be tough on yourself. Just
know you're going to bomb the same way.
I bombed as a comedian. And, uh, I dunno,
find humor in your
shortcomings, you know, and uh,
just keep working on it. And,
uh, you know, believe me, dude,
you're not just going to start
talking to somebody in the next day.
You're not going to be, you know,
shy or whatever. So give you,
give yourself permission to fuck up for
awhile as you work your way through it.
Don't do this shit where you kind of
say half a sentence and then you get
freaked out, and then you stop. And
then the person's looking at you like,
what the fuck?
And then you feel like a Douche and then
you don't try it again until the next
decade. That's not the way
to go. All right, you're 21.
You should be out there drinking should
be out there banging fucking whores and,
uh, having a good time because
someday you're going to get married.
And even if you have a great marriage,
the level of responsibility and the taxes
and what the fucking bankers do to you,
he life's gonna suck. So, uh,
yeah, you can do it. Do it. Don't,
don't, don't, don't fucking, just
don't be too hard on yourself.
That's the biggest thing. When you're
trying to learn new shit, just know,
give yourself permission to suck out at
the beginning and then Bam. There you go.
How's that? There's a nice feel, good
way to end this podcast. You know,
I started off the fuck was
I talking about coffee,
golf and then a leg sweeping a chick,
you know,
was looked like it was going to go off
the rails and look at it ended very
nicely. See, I'm not all bad. Am
I? All right. There you go. Well,
there's your podcast for this week.
I hope you guys enjoyed it. Uh,
you guys have a wonderful
weekend. If you're in the,
the, uh, the Denver area. Hell,
if you're in Cheyenne,
Wyoming,
why don't you drive down and
come down to my show and, uh,
uh, I was gonna just gonna say, I'll
have a drink with you, but I can't,
I got to fucking see.
I got to stay on point here.
I'll have assessed Barilla with you.
I think I'll be doing like
fucking cranberry juice.
And the line is that what the
fuck I'm going to do? Jesus.
That's going to be fucking brutal. All
right. You guys have a good week. And uh,
that is all hate.
And the new segment,
is that a nominees for youtube
clip of the year? Well,
maybe we'll do other month, whatever.
We'll work it out as we do it.
All right guys. All right.
Have a good week. Take it easy.